le 7-8 sport numéro 7 bienvenue sur tv
fils si vous venez de nous rejoindre 26
minutes pour 1 point complet sur
l'actualité sportive avec anthony rech
bonfort anthony bon sens wilfried et
dans un instant les images exclusives de
l'arrivée du skipper versaillais tanguy
de lamotte il vient d'achever son vendée
globe et nous parlerons aussi de hand
avec notre invité sur ce plateau
oui patricia bhl président du comité
départemental de handball nous a rejoint
pour parler évidemment de ce quart de
finale de coupe de la ligue qui
accueille mercredi soir plaisir entre le
havre et mios bonsoir à vous bonsoir
bonsoir à vous on vous entendra dans un
instant auparavant je le disais ces
images exclusives vous étiez antonier
aux sables d'olonne pour la fin du
vendée globe de tanguy de lamotte qu'on
avait suivi tout au long de son périple
autour du monde tout à fait après 98
jours en mer tanguy de lamotte a enfin
franchi la ligne d'arrivée des sables
d'olonne
hier matin aux alentours de 11 heures
j'ai pu suivre au plus près sur le
poteau et sur le bateau tout près du
skipper le final du premier tour du
monde à la voile du marin versailles et
qui s'est révélé au grand public il ya
98 jours tanguy de lamotte avait ouvert
le livre de l' aventure de sa vie il va
pouvoir enfin le refermer avec fierté
sur les premières prévisions le skipper
d'initiative coeur devait voir les
sables d'olonne samedi en fin de journée
finalement le versailles et franchira la
ligne dimanche matin la faute à un vent
capricieux et à une monture usé par les
océans
la soirée prévue en son honneur sur le
port est maintenue pour la route
une dernière vacation par internet avant
les retrouvailles tout près mais je suis
pas encore là donc garder les portes
pour des vols
sincèrement il a fait il a fait une
course géniale il s'est battu il n'a
jamais renoncé et puis à côté ça il nous
a fait plein de petits postes vidéo
il a animé comme il sait le faire parce
que c'est vrai que on avait l'habitude
qu'il le fasse sur les précédents de
course mais c'est vrai que le vendée
c'est une autre médiatisation c'est vrai
et là bas tout ce que nous on savait de
nuit en fête est apparue au grand jour
du plus large public et c'était génial
pour ses incommensurables comme fierté
maintenant on me demande pas c'est mon
fils on me demande si je suis son père
voilà je suis ça perd son bateau vieux
de 14 ans est un illustre héritage celui
de la navigatrice catherine chabaud
première femme à avoir terminé un tour
du monde à la voile
il ya eu d'autres passages de témoin
avant tanguy parce que ce bateau est en
train de boucler son cinquième tour du
monde
c'est un bateau que j'ai fait construire
en 98 pour courir le vendée globe 2000
j'ai l'impression que de tous ceux qui
vont suivi et je suis pas surpris renée
qui veut donner autant d'amour et
d'attention à ce bateau que tony kart
qu'a fait une course magnifique avec le
soleil s'est levé il y à peine une heure
tanguy n'est plus qu'à quelques milles
des côtes
un silence presque pesant règne sur le
ponton je suis impatiente et puis j'ai
pas beaucoup dormi donc en essayant ne
peux rien imaginer
je suis impatiente mais je suis
tellement content de voir toute
l'agitation autour pour lui et il a bien
mérité en fait tout ce qui vient de
faire là il se rend pas compte de ce qui
est préparé en
et j'espère qu'il va très touchés qui va
le garder pendant 40 ans dans son corps
vingt jours après l'exploit du prince
des mers françois gabart ils sont
toujours aussi nombreux à communier avec
le héros du jour il ya douze ans avec
cette performance tanguy de lamotte
aurait visé le podium du vendée globe
il a en tout cas franchi la ligne dans
ses objectifs de départ pour son premier
tour du monde
l'accueil s'est on m'avait dit que c'est
extraordinaire je pense que ça surpasse
tous les tous les objectifs qu'on avait
essayé de me raccrocher à 7
à ce moment là pour m'aider pour me le
décrire donc ouais je l'attendais pas il
y avait des banderoles sur la ligne
d'arrivée
le nombre de bateaux est incroyable
en 2013 le marin versaillais n'est pas
titré mais il aura été le héros de
millions de français et surtout de 15
enfants
ce marin solitaire est aussi solidaire
grâce aux clics sur internet épopée de
tanguy de lamotte a permis de sauver
dips mawa serigne 12 autres enfants
avant la conférence de presse le marin
versaillais a pu déguster son premier
repas à hamburgers et une galette des
rois où il a eu la feuille de quoi faire
la fête
voir les quatre coins du monde traversé
les océans affronter le cap horn
une collection de moments inoubliables
qui vous change un homme
je sais pas encore exactement comment
mais c'est sûr que j'ai changé
mentalement on peut pas vivre 98 jours
tout seul sans changer c'est une tranche
de vie extraordinaire et des moments
difficiles des beaux moments et les deux
feront changer donc c'est sûr j'ai
changé je verrai fur et à mesure comment
un autre tour du monde à la voile
pour l'instant rien n'est arrêté mais le
marin sera sur le bon ton dans quatre
ans avec quel costume celui de skipper
ou de spectateurs son coeur le lui dire
a bien assez tôt
sujet de la rédaction de tv fils les
images les interviews signé anthony rech
et puis pour le montage pascal josèphe
voilà pour tanguy de lamotte qui devrait
prochainement être notre invité sur ce
plateau pour revenir une fois de plus
sur cet exploit 1 98 jours avec un
bateau vieux de 14 ans bouclé ce tour du
monde à la voile on change d'univers ont
quitté les océans pour s'intéresser au
handball oui on va revenir sur arroux
est un ce sujet oui on va revenir un peu
sur terre avec ce quart de finale de
coupe de la ligue 1 de handball féminin
que va accueillir plaisir mercredi soir
à 20 heures et pour en parler avec nous
donc patricia blot président du comité
départemental de handball
je voulais tout d'abord savoir un peu
comment plaisir a été choisi c'est un
tirage au sort il ya des systèmes
particuliers au sein de la fédération
c'est vrai que cela la fédération a
souhaité a délégué l'organisation de ces
finalités de coupe de ligue
professionnelle féminine aux ligues
pareille folie parisienne est donc ce
sont les présidents de ligues notamment
le nôtre georges qatar qui a délégué aux
départements et aux clubs de plaisir
puisque c'est la salle la plus
appropriée pour cela il ya 1200 places
1200 places et c'est une superbe salle
notamment pour tv fils se sait très bien
éclairé découvert le lendemain
donc on a confié cette organisation sur
les yvelines pourquoi parce que par
ailleurs sur les autres départements il
existe d'autres compétitions
ce qui permet d'avoir une compétition
dans chacun des départements et vous
vous le disiez plaisir une salle plutôt
superbe superbe avec 1200 places et a
déjà l'expérience d'une grande
compétition puisque la salle de plaisir
avait accueilli le mondial 2007 mondial
féminin 2007
donc ça a été une superbe occasion de
voir des équipes complètement novatrice
dans cette compétition et alors c'est
aussi l'occasion je présume de
promouvoir un petit peu le handball
féminin dans le département oui oui
c'est l'occasion donc l'idéal ce2 ne
saurait de n'avoir que des spectatrices
j'y crois pas trop quand même mais parce
que les féminines qui sont en évolution
croissante
bon reste quand même représenté près de
30% de l'effectif du département il ya
une évolution positive
oui sur ce nombre d'adhérents de
véritablement parce que c'est vrai qu'on
parle souvent handball féminin on parle
souvent de l'équipe de montigny le
bretonneux il ya des fortunes diverses
en fonction des saisons nationale une
nationale 2 nationale 3 retour en
nationale 2 on attend l'exploit pour la
nationale une mais visiblement ce ne
sera pas pour cette saison bien sûr
difficile difficile
alors qu'est ce qui manque pour franchir
un palier à je connais très bien le
sujet là puisque alors il ya monté voilà
malheureusement arriver à ces niveaux là
c'est un on se heurte à un problème
financier
donc il faut que les collectivités
soutiennent des politiques s'engagent
véritablement oui c'est pour moi je
pense que c'est un problème de volonté
et puis c'est aux femmes de choix
également parce que c'est pas évident
dans le contexte économique actuel
donc deux parce que de jouer en
championnat de france
en seniors et en même temps - 18 c'est
difficile pour le club de montigny avec
le budget dont il dispose
vous le dire que c'est on parle de
montigny mais sur les autres villes du
département c'est la même situation
c'est là c'est peine perdue d'être
d'imaginer un club de hand féminin au
plus haut niveau lors une petite
anecdote il se trouve qu'on a eu un
technicien de la région qui est venu
nous rencontrer
c'est un cts détaché le ministère qui
venu comprendre la situation du handball
sur les yvelines et s'est rendu compte
rapidement que de façon n'aurait jamais
des équipes de haut niveau pour quelles
raisons c'est pour des raisons purement
financières
quand vous avez par exemple ils sont
faire des polémiques un conseil général
qui octroie pour jouer en gp de france
1500 euros à peu près dans d'autres
départements ces cinq à six fois plus
donc imaginez les écarts en fait tout
est lié ne une politique de 2012 mérite
aussi montigny de se maintenir à ce
niveau puisqu'il faut le rappeler
montigny est un des seuls clubs si ce
n'est le seul à ne pas payer ses
joueuses par exemple oui je peux vous
dire que lorsque l'équipe était en
nationale 1 il y avait deux équipes dans
la poule kind indemnisés par leur fille
c'était plus voir des monty d'ailleurs
ce sont les deux qui sont descendus pour
en revenir à ce pour souligner ce que
vous nous dites là est propre à
l'ensemble un des disciplines sportives
sont le département
m'avez-vous jusqu'à du basket par
exemple la trappe ils se sont plaints
également de cette difficulté rencontrée
et tous les responsables de club évoque
la même chose c'est une volonté
financière et est politique et sur le
département des yvelines la priorité
plutôt donné à tous les sports pour tous
les âges
c'est un petit peu les réponses à des
réponses qui sont faites lorsqu'on
interroge les résultats avec moi pour
finir sur sur ce sujet pour en revenir
au match de mercredi soir ont levé de
rideau aussi il y aura une animation un
petit peu particulier à vous glisser une
animation qui prend de l'ampleur
c'est faire du handball fauteuil donc
c'est vrai que le club de montigny a été
à l'origine de avec la commune de
montigny sur ce cette initiative
et comme c'est devenu une une chose
instituée dans le fonctionnement et
d'ailleurs c'est la seul club de la
région ile de france qui a une pratique
régulière
à tel point c'est que ils ont été
contactés il ya quoi quinze jours par le
pg handball donc leader des
professionnels masculins pour essayer de
le finir une animation du même jour donc
il n'est pas impossible de voir des
internationaux français dans les
fauteuils des mois prochain dans les
mois prochains
le handball du psg qui s'approche de
montigny peut-être que dans le football
on verra aussi ça on attend toujours la
décision concernant le centre
d'entraînement des douces et enfin le
psg vers élevé au sein de son centre
d'entraînement dans les mois prochains
où la saison prochaine entend toujours
la réponse
et concernant concernant ces deux
équipes donc le havre et mios et 2,2
club vraiment important de du
championnat de france
oui vous avez un favori pour ce match ou
pas alors je serais tenté de penser que
le avait peut-être de plus de
disponibilité pour remporter la victoire
mais rien n'est fait donc
non mais le havre est actuellement doté
3e et lyon 5e
non je pense qu'on assistera du beau
handball féminin élégant technique et
c'est quand même très plaisant à voir
voilà vous parle vous parliez justement
là de handball féminin élégant et
surtout technique je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui vous plaît plus que
lamballe masculin qui est un peu trop
rugueux à votre à votre avis maintenant
non mais c'est un style différent et
j'avoue que quand je choisis de regarder
des matchs deux internationaux j'aime
autant regarder du handball féminin que
dix ans dom sk mais monde affaires
extra-sportives peut-être aussi est ce
que cette chose sans chercher bien
évidemment la polémique mais ceci dit
non mais c'est vrai que j'ai une
sensibilité peut-être pour avoir
développé le handball féminin montigny
c'est possible mais j'avoue je suis plus
attiré par des équipes de jeunes filles
que à regarder puisque ma petite fille
fait du grand bal aussi que les garçons
mais le hand juste pour revenir sur
cette cette affaire justement d'aider
paris qui concernait les internationaux
français ça a joué sur le nombre de
licenciés sont 7 c à chaque fois qu'il y
a une affaire dans le sport vous le
ressentez une affaire dans le sport nous
en tout cas sur le monde
non non pas du tout vous avez pas
ressenti de novès de licencier arrivant
tôt sur un résultat sportif si le cap
des 7000 cette licence isme donc c'est
la première fois non la sphère du des
paris truqués tout ça c'est ça n'a pas
d'incidence sur les effets ça c'est dole
c'est dommageable pour l'image du
handball mais ça fait partie de ce que
j'appellerais des gamineries
donc c'est d'ailleurs on a eu un point
par notre vice président de la
fédération qui est un avocat qui suit la
faire bien sûr de très près pour cette
affaire qui va se dégonfler tout seul il
ya eu des sanctions qui ont été prises
par les deux les joueurs concernés et ce
en plus c'est des gamineries qu'il
rapporte pas mal et qui peuvent aussi
coûter de coûter très très cher au club
anglais il est pris aux principaux
intéressés mais les clubs possible c'est
forcément les clubs leaders qui perd qui
perdent leurs joueurs ensuite sont un
petit peu sinon vraiment là le cas de
montpellier c'est à dire que c'est
toujours embêtant par les temps qui
courent et du hand féminin du beau jeu
ce sera en tout cas du côté de plaisir
si vous
cette histoire n'hésitez pas à venir
faut en profiter
quand j'ai regardé les compositions des
équipes j'ai fouiné j'ai cherché et j'ai
trouvé une joueuse issue de saint
quentin en yvelines
d'autres étaient exactement de trappes
du côté du havre c'est ça et oui la
gardienne de but linda pradel donc ça
sera l'occasion aussi une femme très
imple réservé mais très gentille à
l'occasion de la de lui poser quelques
petites questions sur son parcours en
balistique
oui elle est d'ailleurs la gardienne
numéro 3 de l'équipe de france à l'été
oralement championnat d'europe voilà
tout neuf est tous derrière le avant
c'est ça le message tout le ca plaisir
pour le genre féminin tout ça plaisir et
derrière linda pradel par exemple voilà
tout c'est tout vous attendez un public
féminin vous l'avez lui glisse à
l'oreille très très bien se passer
toutes les places ont été vendues lé
prix rôle complètement modique donc une
salle pleine normalement j'allais venir
justement les places vendues ça montre
aussi le bas le succès de du handball
féminin où nous avons mobilisé les clubs
donc les clubs proches de plaisir on
fait partie de l'organisation dès le
départ donc ce qu'ils avaient rendu un
petit peu motivés par le par le sujet
très bien merci beaucoup
patrick d'être venu ce soir sur le
plateau télé filez donc rendez-vous 20h
mercredi soir produit avec du handball
fauteuil pour tous si vous le souhaitez
et les images sont à découvrir sur
téléfilm pour cette rencontre de haut
niveau du côté de ces rapidement les
délais le havre face à moi aussi j'ai
publié la deuxième équipe le temps de
retrouver à trouver dans mes fiches on
va faire une petite pause ça permettra
justement d'y voir un petit peu plus
clair on va parler de bike and run oui
c'était l'épreuve de de rentrée pour
l'équipe élite de triathlon du club de
saint quentin en yvelines ce week-end le
club a organisé la deuxième édition du
bike and run de la minière c'était un
premier test physique pour les pour les
champions saint quentinois en pleine
préparation hivernale le résultat avec
des images d'elodie moines au milieu des
300 participants du bike and run de
sérieux concurrents à la victoire
peaufinent leur tactique de course en
pleine préparation hivernale les
triathlètes de l'équipe élite du club
saint quentinois participent à la fête
sont réels objectifs de performance
on va pouvoir s'encourager s'éponger un
petit peu le front celui qui est sur le
vtt il va pouvoir
bichonnés un peu le cours à pied et puis
voilà l'importance et aussi de se faire
plaisir de partager un bon moment avec
tout le monde
c'est un petit peu le lancement de la
saison donc ça fait toujours plaisir de
revenir un peu en terre connue ici à
saint quentin le bike and run et
l'exercice numéro un pour enchaîner les
efforts intenses au delà des 15 km heure
et dans un laps de temps très court
un rythme difficile à encaisser pour un
duo belot brand ray sans trop de repères
physiques
au final les triathlètes saint
quentinois restent maîtres sur leurs
terres
le tandem pozzo di borgo fox ait
s'impose en 35 minutes de course
c'était difficile dès le début parce
qu'on commence par une côte en fait y'a
une cote de à peu près 600 mètres donc
dès le début il faut il faut se mettre
dans le rythme puis après le parcours et
est assez assez roulant mais du coup ça
nous oblige à toujours courir à à une
vitesse régulière et c'est assez
fatigant
huitième à l'arrivée les cadors de
l'équipe élite en termine les jambes un
peu lourd on à la caisse on manque
encore un peu de vitesse mais du coup
c'est peut-être ce qui nous a pénalisés
aujourd'hui mais bon c'est pas trop
grave je sais pas toi thomas ce qui tend
à limiter un peu ouais c'est peut-être
l'état de fraîcheur par rapport aux
autres concurrents mais bon c'était
aussi le but de venir ici faire une
bonne séance voilà la victoire ils
tenteront de la décrocher lors du
premier grand prix de france fin mai et
faire rentrer le club de saint quentin
en yvelines dans le top-5 france
face aux résultats anthony vous êtes
prêts pour nous donner de l'essentiel du
sport de ce week-end du football tout
d'abord le soleil faisait son retour sur
les pelouses saint-quentinoise ce week
end une éclaircie qui n'a pas empêché
guyancourt de sombrer à domicile doit
dès le premier quart d'heure de jeu
linas montlhéry ouvre le score sur le un
cafouillage de la défense centrale pour
la suite de cette première mi temps
c'est une compilation de fautes et
d'action manqué par les rouge et jaune
malgré un but refusé pour hors jeu côté
guyancourt toit en seconde période les
joueurs de détiennent rieder
encaisseront deux autres buts
score final 3 buts à 0 et on passe donc
dans les autres joueurs dans le football
très cool dans l'est dans les autres
matches du week-end trappe sans nez
s'est en revanche imposé à l'extérieur 2
buts à 0 face à colombes en division
d'honneur versailles que l'on voit
apparaître sur le tableau a partagé les
points avec les mureaux concédant le
match nul à domicile 2 buts partout au
classement de promotion d'honneur
malgré leur défaite les joueurs de lèse
lui en cours reste leader avec trois
points d'avancé sur l'entente parisienne
il conserve quelques longueurs d'avancé
dans la poule b et rap conforte sa
troisième place avec 33 points et mais
les trappistes reste à sept longueurs du
leader porcheville trappe troisième du
rugby à présent 14e journée de fédérale
3 plaisir s'est incliné sur la pelouse
de pau ton kobo dans un match encore une
fois très fermé neuf à six autres clubs
à pontault combault qui vise les
playoffs en fin de saison les joueurs de
philippe behar pourront se consoler avec
le point de bonus défensif ils restent à
égalité de points avec vitry à la 4e
place à quatre journées de la fin de la
saison régulière
tout est encore jouable néanmoins pour
les playoffs on en parlait tout à
l'heure en parler de hand justement du
hand féminin
oui et plus près de chez nous à montigny
15e journée de nationale 2 les féminines
de montigny se sont imposés avec la
manière à la maison face à fleury loiret
24 buts à 21 de 8 buts de gabriel parent
loi hier encore une fois elles restent
cinquièmes de leur poule et ont
désormais dix points d'avancé sur le
premier relégable de quoi voir venir du
tennis de table à présent nationales de
troisième journée de nationale 2
assez contrasté pour les clubs saint
quentinois et l'encours s'est
logiquement incliné chez le leader joué
les tours 10 matchs à 7 mai pour
l'entendre voisin saint-arnoult que nous
avions reçu sur le plateau la belle
aventure continue
les joueuses de geoffrey nisand se sont
imposés à nice très facilement dix
matches à 3 au classement les joueuses
vie chinoise sont deuxièmes avec 7
points à égalité de points avec fontenay
quant à elle en cours l'équipe est
quatrième avec 6 points mais rien n'est
joué après après trois journées le
maintien est quand même en bonne voie
pour les deux équipes saint-quentinoise
après les juniors et les cadets qui
n'avait pas perdu leur match de début de
saison c'est du foot us du côté d'el en
cours et bien les seniors à présent
aussi fait leurs débuts débuts plutôt
réussis
oui il avait annoncé un cessez le sait
le titre de champion de france cette
saison et bien les templiers pour leur
retour dans l'élite n'ont pas manqué
tout simplement ce retour les joueurs de
manu charest se sont imposés chez les
spartiates d'amiens 21 points à 14
une victoire qui devrait lancer leur
saison et puis une dernière information
c'est de la boxe éducative à la mairie
nous avions reçu le directeur sportif à
la semaine dernière justement du boxing
de la verrière est on sûr sur ces
championnats régionaux catégorie cadets
2 titres encore une fois un la
ribambelle continue du côté de
gennevilliers oumar diallo en moins de
68 kg et il y as kamal chez les moins de
81 kg l'emportent facilement finale
merci anthony
voilà pour les résultats sport tout à
l'heure nous parlions du vendée globe
nous étions sables d'olonne et on va
partir pour le maroc à présent avec le
4l trophy
oui ce raid humanitaire réservé aux
étudiants qui part de la france pour se
rendre au maroc est donné dès des
fournitures scolaires et paramédical
notamment de la part des équipes alger
avec nous l'équipage saint quentinois
qui est sur la route que le l'équipage
quoi trophy dont william hill oeuvre non
soir william
alors comment se passent ces premiers
jours de raid c'est difficile ça va
c'est pas trop difficile on a fait pas
mal de l'affairé mieux et on y arrive on
qu'est-ce qui est le plus dur là c'est
justement s'occuper de la voiture
s'acclimater aux nouvelles conditions de
températures un peu probable dans le
désert on perd une liaison un petit peu
compliqué forcément avec le maroc est ce
que william nous entends encore
alors on vous a récupéré vous à
récupérer vous disiez donc la voiture
tenez quand même le choc c'est ça malgré
quelques problèmes de l'heure on n'avait
vraiment pas mal de dégâts mais on a
tombé en plein la poire
on va travailler tout le véhicule pour
l'histoire auprès de la
mais alors est-ce que vous avez déjà
rencontré quelques jeunes pour pu donner
quelques fournitures que vous avions
embarqués dans le coffre du véhicule
2 les fournitures donc à une cérémonie
de remise de fournitures humanitaires
dont humanitaire est génial on a
rencontré beaucoup nous ont donné près
de 3000 sur les bivouacs le loiret a
vraiment beaucoup de personnes donc il
ya beaucoup d'échangés humanitairement
est il vraiment entre nous est fait
au-delà de l'aspect humanitaire vous
avez jeté un coup d'oeil au classement
malheureusement avoir normalement merci
à williams et donc à bastien qui est à
côté de vous les deux représentants de
yvelinois qui font partie de l'équipage
quattro filles merci à tous les deux on
les suivra un régulièrement on verra
comment ça évolue et on suivra leur
classement on essaiera d'avoir la
liaison régulièrement avec le maroc
voilà pour ce point sur le 4l trophy et
le 7-8 sport qui s'achève pour ce soir
oui n'hésitez pas à commenter l'émission
sur twitter et nous donner tous les
résultats de vos clubs à lundi prochain
bonne soirée